i think that
people from the outside look in and will
be like look well jeezy obviously has
grown
into who he is today right
and you could say whatever you want to
say i just saw the interview with
his old partner um that was on the yeah
where he was like look that versus
scratching any
any street cred he could ever have a
mystery yeah i don't know what he was
thinking with that yeah
but um i know he was thinking it's a
look they could do anything
for look you know he's hosting the
[ __ ] talk show like i think
jeezy's thirsty right now he he reaching
he thirsty he don't know what to do
[ __ ] ain't [ __ ] with him he ain't
got no real [ __ ] with him were you uh
around when the
the the gucci beef was pretty pretty
serious
um it was always serious but
you know um should i know i actually ran
into gucci
one time i ran into i ran into all them
on my own time
you know out here like what's happening
wakka too and me and wakka
we cool like that's that's the homie
right ran into waka we chopped it up
2010. months later i run into
gucci in my studio remember that yeah me
and gucci chopped it up he was so cool
i'm like damn bro i
don't like this [ __ ] you feel me gucci
was cool as [ __ ] and um
and yes but then i've been in clubs
and we was all together and ain't
nothing happened you know what i'm
saying so
i was confused but that's what fred was
telling me he'd be like man like
i'm like friends the type of
[ __ ] if we got problems we're in
the same place something's gonna happen
bro that's what i was confused we'd be
in central station and then [ __ ] be
right over there and i'm like okay well
let's get it